all right guys i've got jeff here with
me thanks so much for doing this awesome
thanks
i'm super excited to talk because i
think last year about this time uh when
we had a conversation we talked a lot
about bitcoin the macro environment uh
kind of all the chaos uncertainty and i
think we both hoped that the world would
kind of calm down things would become
much clearer
unfortunately it seems like it only got
exasperated right it got more chaotic it
got more uncertain everything from
some of the central banking issues to
obviously the war in europe and a number
of other things so maybe we could just
start with this idea of central banking
and some of the problems that it seems
like we're starting to see uh
if we start here in the united states uh
it feels like the fed is using their
two or three tools uh the best that they
can but we have inflation at you know
eight percent officially probably in the
teens unofficially uh it looks like the
march numbers are going to come in way
higher and uh doesn't necessarily seem
like they have a plan as to how to kind
of get this under control so how do you
see something like the federal reserve
and kind of high inflation and the
economic situation that they're facing
um it's it's a function of the market
they they have no choice and
and i mean globally all of central banks
have no choice um because because
they're trapped
i in and
you know my my premise or my thesis on
technology being deflation area trying
to drive prices down if prices come down
you have a credit collapse and the
credit collapse keeps on winding all
over the world and that and it just
keeps on unwinding so
so for
and
when i wrote my book um
there was 185 trillion dollars of
spending in the world a stimulus in the
world to raise or to increase global gdp
by 46 trillion
and i projected because technology was
moving faster and faster that was what
was to come was way higher
rate exponent an exponential rate of
debt creation to be able to try to stop
deflation from happening
um
and
and so they're trapped and you can
expect more and more and more because if
they stop
you you literally have a global credit
collapse and in our economies everything
is built on top of that credit market
so how do they if we get in the
situation right usually they would just
inflate their way out of it uh but if
you already have high inflation is the
game kind of
don't use our tools allow for some sort
of
recessionary event to take place or go
ahead and accelerate the inflation like
is that the path is like recession or
inflation choose your poison so even
today
there's there's more stimulus coming and
and so you i think to to simplify this
that inflation deflation debate like
just to simplify it and
first principles
ask yourself
what would happen if government stopped
easing
what would you see what would you see if
the market was a free market
and what we would see is
is cash would explode in value but cash
for a while
u.s cash dollar
dollars would but after that after the
banking failures over and over and over
cascading around the world because it
would just keep on the cat that counter
party risk would take down everything
the only cash that would
explode in value is the stuff under your
mattress
um and and
prices would completely collapse but
into that vacuum
dictators would rise
into because you wouldn't have food on
the streets you would you're on the
shelves you wouldn't uh you would there
would be no banking institutions there
would be no institutions left every
institution is built on top of this
global credit mess
and and it's a staggering size
of
imaginary money
and it has to
keep on blowing up
a bigger imaginary money to keep it
solvent
otherwise you initiate that credit
collapse so they have no choice
so
so they'll raise you'll get
raise interest rates and even the threat
of raising interest rates the the the
credit market is so they both both the
bond markets start to collapse and the
credit and they
and the equity markets start to collapse
and as that starts
to happen but they have to run fiscal
policies and they have to and as this
happens it doesn't just move into
central banking it moves into
consumers demand
more money to pay for higher prices and
it overtakes the and it overtakes the
political establishment
and politicians become the central bank
so the central banks get corrupted by
the state
there is no independence
and again just go back and ask yourself
what type of market would you see in a
free market and you'd see no market
because they're the manipulation is part
of the function globally
of money
of of money of central banking yeah when
we think about the macro situation uh or
kind of the global environment uh it
scares the hell out of me i think scares
the hell out of a lot of people if that
was the case but if we then go and we
look at specific examples at the country
level so individual uh situations we
have lebanon as a recent example where
um the stats that i've seen are
the local currency has collapsed 90
percent uh the economy has collapsed 60
percent in about two and a half years
and the central bank recently declared
bankruptcy and uh obviously
it goes without saying but the people
the citizens of lebanon actually get
crushed here uh it's an incredible dire
situation for them um
but is that an example of how they get
over their skis or kind of it gets out
of control they don't make the right
monetary and fiscal policy decisions and
quite literally they go bankrupt over it
so remember and
um this is a global global worldwide
structural problem
where technology is advancing at a rate
that is bringing down devices and
globally central banks have to try to or
they're trying to
print into it and eventually as they
print into it
what which will happen in in the u.s too
and it'll be probably the last domino to
fall but but
but as they print into it
they're actually so if they stop
printing
you have what i told you before you have
a credit collapse and the credit is our
entire market that we live on top of all
houses fall precipitously um everything
falls bank banking fail but if and so
you won't have no choice but to print
into that
and so
so you're printing into an inflation
rate that is staggering
and
we look at those other countries as
banana republics
and what happens to their citizens and
what and we think oh there's high crime
there and it's just
those people are ugly people
it's it's a function of broken money
that that turns people into
doing whatever they need to to feed
their families
and the same thing can be said for el
salvador before el salvador went to the
bitcoin standard high crime rate high
gang gangs if you look at peru and the
food prices today and people
rising up on the streets and they
and and all of these things all over the
world are connected to the same monetary
policy people don't turn against people
the divi when when money is not broken
they turn against when when they're
fighting for survival and politicians
can create us versus then their
narratives because of the
the
the high wealth on one side because of
equity because
house prices went up stock prices went
up and the massive
poverty on the other side
and in that scenario you can't build
walls high enough to keep the the the
middle class poor out that have been
been hurt by those policies so let's
call uh increasing food prices um and
other types of issues that are driven by
this central banking
structural failure or
complexity uh how is that
affected in relationship to something
like an external shock where we have
with the russia ukraine conflict where
it's very obvious that they're a large
wheat producer natural gas etc and
people are saying look if fertilizer
prices spike if wheat can't get out of
the region
there is the potential for
much higher prices in a good situation
in a bad situation literally famine in
some parts of the world um and so if the
long kind of macro structure trend is
the central bank is going to cause these
issues because they just can't get out
of their way
and then you have an external shock that
also is going to drive
food prices higher like do those two
things converge and just magnify the
problem or are they two separate
situations they're exactly the same
situation
in fact
there's monetary policy um
and this is probably deeper than we can
explore
on the show but um
but monetary policy is the rise of the
war in in ukraine as well
because effectively what you have is us
being able to
get free energy in oil by pressing a
button
and and russia's selling their oil
or their their
value and their labor
in stuff that it gets devalued
and so that
and so as you do that and
there's one country that has a monetary
standard of the world and can keep on
getting an advantage in trade and
energy prices is
derivative of everything else and you
have an advantage in trade
other people have a disadvantage
and so their economies suffer as a
result of the uh of that
advantage and disadvantage so what china
did in in 2015 with the same thing they
realized that
that the u.s couldn't pay its bills
anymore so for a long time china was a
beneficiary of this trade they kept
labor rates high low
and if late if if the economy didn't
function really well in the united
united states in other words if interest
rates went up the u.s economy would have
collapsed
and therefore
all of the buying from china would have
collapsed too and their economy would
have collapsed so it was a it was a
beneficial relationship
but but china pegged their dollar their
yuan to the to the u.s dollar
um and you had the
low labor rates high labor rates and
that balance all over the world has to
equal zero
so when
and and to keep interest rates low
china bought us bonds correct
but when they stopped buying us bonds in
2015 and realized u.s can't pay the back
their debts
and and they're not going to pay back
their debts so they took the money and
they kept the peg they took them took
the money and hot as they're hollowing
out the the
the us economy
um
and put it into
safe haven assets rare earth minerals
real estate all over the world
kind of expanding their
their footprint all over the world with
that same trade balance
um instead of putting it in the us
dollars so what did u s dollar have to
do to stop
a depression at that time
they had to monetize their own debt and
they had to actually take their
essentially take their citizens money
um
and make the rich richer and the poor
poorer
by monetizing
their debt and that that creates this
geopolitical rival
um that is getting stronger and stronger
and stronger because of that same
imbalance so as everybody's pegging
everybody's trying to find their way to
what is what is valuable and what russia
just did is said
you can print your money all you want
my oil is more valuable than your
printed dollars
and we're gonna we're gonna price it in
something else we're gonna start pricing
it in something else now if the a lot of
people are worried okay they're gonna
price it in yuan or they're and i
suspect if you just do the game theory
on this
china isn't going to be the reserve
currency of the world like who would
trust that to happen in another country
having a reserve currency in the world
including china would they want that
because then they would have to run the
structural imbalance that u.s is running
and you would port
us labor rates would fall a lot
china labor rates would rise
and industry would move back uh
back and so so that balance all over the
world house and um
and so what what you need
is a neutral reserve asset
that as
countries do
trade with one another and labor moves
up or they have a strong industry labor
moves up and it rebalances automatically
and so we don't have that today um and
and all countries are trying to
essentially
look inwards and create policies that
don't realize that we live in an
interconnected world
for their own good
and their and and it's
it's driving massive chaos supply chains
chaos that is bound to get a lot worse
like that we are we're we're a long way
from done on this
so what you can expect in the macro
economic landscape is
if you look back 20 years and we think
oh we live in a really safe world
everything's every everything's great
and it seems like these iterations are
getting worse and worse and it's hard to
believe and we're sucked into the news
media over and over and over in these
events
every one of them is connected and
they're getting bigger and bigger
oscillations
and i find myself
you want to react to the events
but if you look at the
structure and what has to happen they're
going to get worse i wish i didn't have
to say that but they're going to get a
lot worse yeah it's funny because uh i
read uh ray dalio's book changing world
order and in it
much of what you're saying
this is not new right and his whole
kind of focus for the last number of
years has been go back in history look
at the rise and fall of various
economies
geographic
military powers and also
empires and
this idea that you're a small country
with no power and no wealth you
eventually
focus on investing in education
technology et cetera you then rise in
both military might and also in wealth
eventually your citizens become wealthy
feel wealthy they take on tons of debt
your country takes on tons of debt you
then basically get overextended and at
some point somebody else rises and
replaces you and this is a cycle that
continues over and over again
what's fascinating is it feels like
there's a lot of countries that are all
doing this at the exact same time
and uh to your point about china making
very specific decisions i don't know how
clear it is to the u.s that
we are following history and if we don't
do something we get the same results
that people have gotten you know for
thousands and thousands of years at the
end of uh kind of these very long uh you
know positive runs for our country
yeah um
and i think the one thing ray dalio
misses is how different bitcoin is in
this uh transition and he thinks he he
believes now he's incentive to incented
to believe this too because a lot of his
investments are in china
but he believes china is the
is the rise and it will become
that new superpower or
global reserve or some something like
that and i categorically dismiss that
that's not going to happen and it's not
going to happen because of bitcoin
and i can't imagine the world looking
at it
at that
type of model
which is actually not a free market
model which is if you look at the rise
of debt in china there's never been
faster growth of debt for a country if
you look at their debt to gdp ratio it's
off the charts
the known not the hidden dark pools
um
of debt
and and that debt has created a ma
fastest growth forever
forever as well but it has to be repaid
too
and and so who is going to trust
um a country that look at cbdc like look
if you look at the rights and freedoms
of individual chinese people and if you
look at what that looks like
do you trust the truth coming out of
china and and and would you trust that
type of
policy around the globe
um i suspect not i said so
so and that's actually what's so
different about bitcoin a lot of people
miss this um
that
and actually i'll tie it back through
history that's probably better
technology has always been deflationary
from from the invention of the wheel
to
to everything we do it's it's our ideas
put into things or technology that makes
our lives better right and that that
reduces the labor component and remove
or or today in a lot of cases removes
the labor component
and so
but it used to happen if you go back to
roman times it used to happen over a
slower period
and but because we always had hard money
um but hard money couldn't gain velocity
so you could we couldn't have fast
enough velocity to do good global trade
in in gold
you had to have a credit market built on
top to build a
and that credit market once it built on
top
and sends the system to expand credit
and and reduce the amount of gold in a
in a system
and at the end of that bubble gray dalio
talks about this at the end of that
bubble the debt can't be repaid back so
governments always either seize the cold
or they they start driving more and more
inflation and a function of that whole
model is we we believe it today is two
percent inflation is required for a
productive economy and it's a false
construct we believe it though so it's
real for us
and it's it's a it is a construct if you
have to build a debt
bubble that has to keep growing and then
eventually that debt bubble has to turn
into eight percent inflation fourteen
fifty percent inflation it has to
um
and and so what that meant is
in the roman times
uh you would have a currency failure
every five or six hundred years
and then as you advance through history
as technology is moving more and more
moving faster and faster you had
debt bubbles and there's
not not the small ones the massive debt
bubbles that kind of
tends to take countries to war
um
every 100 years
and today you have them
if you project what actually would
happen
you have them every 50 years remember
the u.s defaulted on their debt in 1971
and and so now the petrodollar is
is effectively defaulting now and so you
have every 50 years and that all of
those things are caused by technology
moving faster and faster and faster and
it's moving so and we're projecting
backwards all of our
all of what we think looks backwards
instead of looking forwards if you look
forward on the technology access access
is moving at a rate we can't even
comprehend so that exponential rate of
technology now moving forward
means if you run a monetary policy that
requires inflation it means you have to
collapse
you'll have these debt bubbles at a
faster and faster
rate
and that's where bitcoin's so different
you gain monetary velocity through the
network you can have unlimited monetary
velocity without
creating a massive debt bubble on on top
and so people think oh it has to act
like gold
it doesn't act like gold you can
i can trade
we can trade bitcoin over and over in
india to to
to
el salvador to canada to here all in
instant trans
transactions on on lightning and and and
it's it so you don't have to
store gold in a vault build a monetary
and go back and forth on on on slow
rails that change
changes the very nature of debt markets
and it changes the very nature of
how things move and allow technology to
create abundance for all of us actually
yeah when you start to think about uh
that central banking system
obviously the oscillations get larger uh
the uncertainty becomes deeper there's
more fear i think of kind of the unknown
uh moving forward
but also i think we're getting some of
those fears pulled into the future or
i'm sorry pulled into the present where
uh in canada seeing the trucker uh
protest uh and having the canadian
government essentially treat them as
terrorists and go ahead and seize uh
whether it was bank accounts or go after
citizens who had donated etc
but at the same time uh those financial
sanctions or
censorship uh also being applied to the
russian
government given their directions in
ukraine
freezing central bank
assets
and i think most people would say okay
those are you know
whether you agree or not
situations where
somebody is engaging in an activity that
somebody else that's at the government
level disagrees with and so they're
taking action
but then if we kind of extrapolate out
even further
we have also seen
as part of the russian sanctions
going after the oligarchs where it's not
just taking money out of a bank account
it's
literally confiscating physical assets
taking their yachts or their property
etc
and it just feels like whether it's the
truckers whether it's
the russian central bank
which really ends up punishing the
people not the leaders
or it's going after
these oligarchs
it's a guilty
you know kind of uh sentence before
there's any sort of due process um and
maybe sometimes that's
supposed you know maybe sometimes it's
actually uh effective or uh necessary in
them and the moment of war is a little
bit different obviously than when you're
dealing with something like maybe the
protest
but how do you think about the
relationship between financial
censorship and and what seems to be an
acceleration and the more normalization
of
a lot of those sanctions
along with some of these central banking
issues that we've been talking about
yeah it's a this is a
it's not a complex topic but it seems
complex because there's so much emotion
tied to it and depending on where your
emotion will
will drive you to a construct
you will
either okay
in russia that's right we should censor
those people
uh or should we we should cut them off
and in truck in the truckers that's uh
that's that's that's wrong
and they're actually
in
similar
um
so and i and i can say this because in
in the truckers i i was one of the
bitcoin key holders
of some
and
and sitting in canada which i think is a
free nation
and having emergency powers act and
realizing that my bank account could be
seized
is unbelievable to actually think that
worse
outside of canada people are looking
this is not a democratic country anymore
if if and because the protests were
peaceful and and whether you agree with
the truckers or not um the pro
most of the protests uh were were
peaceful
um
and and and then retroactively
for something it was a peaceful trudeau
emergency powers act and anybody who
donated to them could have their
their um
their bank accounts frozen worse than
that
75 or so of canadians thought that that
was the right move
it in and and that alone
blew me away it blew me away how many
people that thought
and because because i don't think people
realize that once that happens
what if you donate to the wrong party
and then the new party comes in and says
um
retroactively i don't like the way you
stand up for free speech um and the
retroactively sees your bank accounts so
these things are
wildly interconnected
um and but we tend to we tend to
polarize on one of the issues that we
believe in
and then we will be on the exact
opposite side of that issue
on on somebody something somebody else
believes in uh believes in
and so
so
and probably this is the simplest way to
to look at it
capitalism and communism
um free markets and communism are the
exact same construct under printed money
democracies fail under printed money and
and why
and and why do they have to take more
and more control
is because
we don't have a vote in a democracy
on inflation
yet inflation is the number one impact
in all of our lives because it's
actually a theft of our money
or in a transfer of our money to
somebody else
but we don't have a vote in a
democratically held election on on
inflation and and so if you taxed a
hundred percent of the companies in 1990
or into sorry 2019 100 of all of the
wealth in the us and
you can pay for half of what the
spending is right now
so they have to hide
the spending rate in inflation and
because that impoverishes so many people
the same people that it impoverishes
have their hands out for more money
from and so it empowers
governments to come in and say we're
going to help you
but they're actually killing you
by by printing more money and
transferring that wealth and and and how
do they do that
they look like heroes going after the
rich that they're making richer
and creating divide in society but that
same extension is not just in your
country it's in every country and it
turns into
my country against your country and and
we believe in those false narratives
well our individual rights and freedoms
are being taken away
to control the narratives
yeah what's fascinating about it is uh
if you take it in the united states
there's a recent legislation that was
put forward uh it's basically the
billionaire income tax right and there's
a minimum 20 tax they want to levy and
based on the name of it you would think
that it was for billionaires uh but
except for uh it actually the threshold
is 100 million dollars and again 100
million is very very wealthy so uh uh
maybe the 100 million dollar income tax
doesn't sound as good as the billionaire
income tax so some some marketing there
uh but i think what it signals is two
things one to your point uh going after
the wealthy regardless of how they got
it and regardless of uh it being less of
a
evil verse good more so an educated
versus uneducated is really how they get
to that level of wealth um
it makes them look like they're doing
something
but the other piece of it is if you go
after their income you know i think it's
uh uh steve schwartzman as an example uh
he made a billion dollars i think last
year uh and he gets paid like a couple
hundred thousand dollar salary and it's
you know 999 million dollars or whatever
that he gets all through uh dividends
and and kind of capital gains type uh uh
revenue and so when you think of that
the income tax almost feels like uh it's
more of a marketing stunt than it is
actually trying to raise uh uh capital
for the state
like say this over and over and over
again because it's so important most of
government revenue comes from inflation
a hidden repressive tax
that is delivered that is levied on the
middle class and poor that they have no
realization that somebody's walking into
their house stealing their money and
their wages and their time and
transferring it to other people
and until that is brought into light
and and and politicians are advocating
on
on truth
then all of this all of the other things
that people are talking about on top of
this
is is just nonsense
and but but but people believe in those
narratives and people believe i would i
would i would venture to say
99 of people all over the world 98 of
people all over the world believe
inflation is required for a productive
economy
and they never asked why like why
why is inflation required for a
productive economy
um
like
does that make sense does it make sense
what rate of theft is required for a
productive economy because that's what
you're saying
when you think about this i know you
have this idea of capitalism and
socialism end up being the same thing in
this environment explain what you mean
by that
because on a structural issue that you
have to have inflation and you don't
have a vote in a free free market just
ask again go back to
what would happen in a free market
prices would collapse to to
zero everywhere everything would
collapse
and so
so so we tell ourselves
we we dismiss that because well we can't
let that happen
but that's the first principle answer
that's what would happen in a free
market because this credit bubble
that that we live in
would unwind and so we'd we we dismiss
what okay well it's kind of free
right there's no no kind of free and
then and then while you have manipulated
money
every price signal
has to be manipulated in fact as you
have manipulated money if if you have
min and money is just an abstract
concept for our time
people don't actually don't want more
money they want when they think more
money will give them correct
and so so when you have misinformation
and money
which is the just the division of our
labor and it's all it is is trust
all over the world
wouldn't it be obvious that if you if
you are
trying to remove trust trying to give
misinformation and money you'd have
misinformation everywhere in society
and that's what's and that's what's
happening and and so to be able to
essentially and i don't want to call it
a crime
but
but be able to per
perpetuate that lie
you have to control
you have to remove individual rights and
freedoms and drive more control
to perpetuate that lie
and and it comes from and
this probably the most frightening thing
is
the people most hurt by that lie
um are the most susceptible to believing
in it and will vote to keep it going
because
because the thing that's hurting them
and transferring that wealth to to
to
the
0.1 percent at an increasing rate
um
and it's not the by the way it's not the
billionaires that are creating it it's a
system that's creating it the
billionaires are just
they what would you do
if you had asked that if you had your
choice of cash that was being devalued
would you put that into a house would
you put that into something else that
couldn't be devalued and if a country
was trying to stop you from doing that
you would move your assets to another
country
so every human human nature would say
i'm going to get this money out of here
to save it just like china's done to try
to move
their assets all around the world for
themselves for the same reason so that's
a structural issue
that's that's caused by this
is printing money
but society votes for it
because
and again going back to that free market
just ask yourself a simple hypothetical
question if a politician today told you
the truth
and said listen here's what it looks
like i'm going to advocate for a free
market and i'm going to let all prices
collapse and and this is what it means
for everything
what i just said about no food on
shelves
banking failures and everything else
would you vote for
them like that it's no one would vote
for them they'd be they would be
ostracized so
so politicians are incented to lie
and and drive more and more inflation
which and and they're instead to say i'm
going to help you
poor
the person who's been most hurt from
this because of those rich people
and they're going to print more money to
transfer more wealth
and and but they they have to now and
that's why you need a parallel system
like bitcoin
because this is this is a system global
system problem that can't solve it from
the system
it's impossible you have either complete
credit collapse or you have inflation
rate it keeps on it keeps on going and
and again to
to measure this in months
when when this is playing out and it's
going to it's going to play out for a
long time is going to people are going
to be
if there if there's a tightening
things will start collapsing really fast
and you can expect yield curve control
you can expect massive easing at some
point so if we're measuring at what
point i can't tell you it's just
but but essentially what you're what all
bets right now
our bets on
when government is going to stimulate
more correct nothing nothing else
matters right and so we don't live in a
free market we live in a
a bet on what's what's going to happen
with people stimulating
more
that's why a parallel system is required
because this system can't solve it and
that parallel system which is bitcoin i
think it's inevitable
is is as people are starting to
understand what you've been saying for a
long time what i've been saying for a
lot of people have been saying for a
long time they're building that parallel
system and that parallel system on
bitcoin is getting stronger and stronger
and stronger and it's moving at a
velocity and was building on top of that
is going to
remake the world under under a system
that looks more like a free market yeah
what's fascinating about this is uh
there's a gentleman mark spitznagel who
runs a fund
and the whole idea is he loses money
every day by buying uh you know
basically out of the money options
betting on a market downturn and so he
loses money sometimes for years
and
when there is a market downturn he's the
best performing hedge fund and he
basically catches up and then passes
everybody and so in fact uh i think it
was february and march of 2020 he
returned like 4 400 percent right
and uh he has a book uh the dow of
capital and i always tell folks it's
probably one of my favorite books to
read and in it uh he has a lot of
analogies and and uh kind of frameworks
in which he thinks about but one of them
is this idea of planting a special kind
of tree and the whole idea is over a
long period of time uh it grows and it's
very strong uh and
that's similar to what bitcoin's doing
but the other piece of it is he
explicitly calls out the market
intervention and he says if every single
day you show up right and you're
constantly intervening in the markets
you distort all the price signals you
completely remove the free market and
what you actually do is as a human you
probably make the problems worse and
that's exactly what we're talking about
right you do make the problems worse and
then only because because they're people
are short-term in nature and they have
mandates for four years and they're
short-term and now i need to get elected
and you make the the problem cascades
way worse and they they miss all the
second third derivatives
of those problems which are and a lot of
monetary monetary theories like
ask right now what does monetary
modern monetary theory look like where
you can just print money ask those
people right now
what what just happened with russia
saying
we're not pricing
us dollars and so
you
if you're a nation state that controls
the uh
currency of the world
and somebody else wants to price their
raw materials that you need in something
else
it's checkmate
when you think of that um
bitcoin i think is uh probably the only
way out for a lot of folks uh in this
environment uh how do you see bitcoin
playing out and why do you see it as the
only way out
um
when i wrote my book and i
i only had a paragraph on bitcoin in in
my book but because i wanted to talk
about the structural issues and then a
potential way out but i have been
looking i've been talking about this for
10 plus years um and
trying to find a way out of this and
really for my kids for for for
and
and
you
probably
the simplest way i could explain this is
throughout history same thing ray dalio
talks about you could just say
if
if
a money could be corrupted for some
people's gains
over some people's expense negative
positive externalities negative
externalities
it will be
not it might be it will be for sure and
history proves it
seizing of gold
uh changing of
the rules of gold history proves that
that will happen always and it's because
human nature is inside that state we
care about ourselves first
rather than some far-off land
and so so
we will do that humans will do that if a
money can be controlled
bitcoin is the only thing that i've see
seen
that removes that
temptation or power from us our human
nature
to
compete against other people and and and
it's kind of a profound thing because it
moves
global competition to global cooperation
and a different shelling point
um and
and and assuming that stays true bitcoin
remains decentralized which i suspect it
will
um and and then it's out of the hands of
people to be able to manipulate it now
when i people say okay well why are
prices going down manipulation
on on bitcoin if more and more people
are buying there are people
creating leveraged products on bitcoin
today and some of the exchanges some of
the exchanges will fail on bitcoin and
when this price goes
make sure make sure you hold bitcoin on
your own private wallet and your own own
own keys
um because
over time when this thing goes parabolic
it's going to take out a whole bunch of
exchanges that are levered and you're
going to see you're you're going to see
what happens because bitcoin doesn't
care it doesn't have that counterparty
risk unless you impose that counterparty
risk by
by leveraging yourself under somebody
else's exchange
but but that decentralization
and taking that money out of control of
human nature
means
we're forced to cooperate
and and
in
labor we will often miss that the buyer
and seller
are actually the same person
so all of our labor
shows up as somebody buying our labor
and but but because we miss that so we
miss that
we can use zoom now for effectively free
and that removed a whole bunch of other
businesses
because because now that our that
message can transfer
touch millions of people all over the
world essentially for uh for free
um
and
yet we don't want prices to fall over
we want our house prices to go up
forever
yet all the things we choose in our
lives we want more value in
so we miss that it's the same thing
right all of our labor is somebody
else's buying and and so we but we but
we want all of our things we choose to
go down in price yet we want our assets
to go up in price and and that's because
of the system
that wouldn't look like that system
prices of housing would fall to the
utility value
they wouldn't be used as a store of
value
in a in a market that that didn't would
require leverage and leverage and
leverage
and and so so all of these prices as
technology removed labor
would fall in in lockstep that's why i
say it would be the most the broadest
distribution of tech winners would we
would still compete to create products
which still create to create
great great technology that and the only
way to win would be to delivering value
to somebody else in their terms that's
the only way to get more bitcoin
um in their terms and out and they in
the in what would happen out of that is
prices would fall everybody would win so
that's the world we're moving to it's
going to be chaotic on the way on the
way there if you're if you're living in
bitcoin if you're managing your world in
bitcoin right now what you're seeing is
prices against bitcoin fall
forever every price falls forever but if
you're measuring your world in a in in a
fiat currency you're thinking prices are
going to rise forever yeah when uh you
recently went to el salvador and i think
that they're probably the closest thing
so far to that world now of course
everything's not priced in bitcoin uh
every single citizen is not even holding
bitcoin or interested in bitcoin um but
when you went what were some of your
takeaways in terms of
kind of what they're doing and is that
an example of uh kind of where the world
is headed or is it maybe not so clear
yet
um
there's a lot of powers that to be
that are trying to stop that
we're not trying to stop
so international powers to be
international system that are trying to
stop that experiment because once el
salvador is uh for a a currency
then other
than then it's a currency everywhere
other nations can just say it's a
currency and and and it moves around the
world i you're going to see some of that
you're going to see some of that at this
conference
um
but
um
it is early it is really early in el
salvador in this but but what i saw is
again i've traveled extensively all over
the world i've gone to some places that
people people think oh why would you go
there it's really unsafe
and i heard the same thing going to el
salvador
and i saw the exact opposite i saw i saw
just beautiful people
and
maybe for the first time in a long time
hope
and that's really powerful
when when because because instead she
crime comes out of
uh
i met a teacher at school and teaches in
in bitcoin and
um and and what's happening here and his
school enrollment went from 200 to 800
this year
and we met all a bunch of the kids and
we talked to the the to the kids in el
salvador what he said and he told us a
story i said how many did you people did
you lose to gangs
over the last two months
and and the number out of 800 and 840
students they lost 41 to gangs
in two months
and and i asked why
and he said well here's when there isn't
an economic system
and the gangs provide an economic system
then he gave an ex
of two young brothers the mom had cancer
and they didn't have any money for
cancer matters and and so they joined a
gang to try to try together when the mom
died they came back to school
they they dropped or the gang came back
to school so it's an economic
calculation that people get forced into
this and then the gang gets stronger and
stronger and and drives
it drives a bunch of
force
to be able to make uh to make that again
most of this comes down to an economic
calculation and when you break that
and people see hope that they have
another path
they take the other path and that
entrepreneurial adventure i met at the
guy he calls himself the bitcoin taxi
guy and you should meet him he's just
like full of energy and he was
dirt poorer i think he had a grade three
education um
and
and no hope and and when bitcoin came in
he wanted to learn it so he learned it
now he has three different drivers
working for him everybody that goes
there go looks up the bitcoin taxi guy
and he's expanding and you should see
that that hope is palpable like it's so
so it's so it's so cool to meet people
on the ground watch actual people
not what you hear through the media and
what it looks like for them
it is still early though it is still
it's not widely uh accepted there
there's still
how does it what does it what does it
look like here but but it's
but i would say really helpful looks
good yeah but part of this i think is uh
hope is a huge piece of it it also feels
like um i call it energy right in terms
of uh we have a young leader uh
regardless of uh whether somebody thinks
they're an expert on salvadorian
politics or not um
and nobody can tell anyone's intentions
in the future but you see this in el
salvador
you see it here in miami you see it in a
couple of other regions around the world
where a young person who understands
technology understands innovation has a
pretty good uh handle on the internet
and things like twitter etc uh and they
just are excited right and they say
listen i am enthusiastic about our
future and i always tell uh founders
that enthusiasm is contagious if you
show up every day you have high energy
guess what everyone else is going to
show up and have high energy too totally
and it feels like uh
what you have to ask yourself is what is
that spark what kicks off the enthusiasm
what if you have the enthusiasm it leads
to hope if you have the hope then you
actually probably get results and uh in
in this case uh both in miami and in el
salvador bitcoin was a huge piece of
that story and i think that we're going
to see this kind of roll out across the
world as people realize
a lot of people believe in this and uh
and we're going to have to be pro
bitcoin in order to uh to make this
happen yeah i actually thought about
that and that maybe this would be a call
out to a whole bunch of people that are
either in bitcoin
or just in bitcoin but just holding
bitcoin
we all create the world we want to live
in
and
and through our idea exchanges competing
for ideas um and
and
i want to live in a world
that is filled with truth hope abundance
and and so holding bitcoin now isn't
enough for me
and i and and as i see this this play
out because it's not enough for me just
to have
more wealth in an economic system and
it's probably not enough to drive
bitcoin
but it's it bitcoin will happen but can
i influence the rate of change in this
by myself actively participating in it
not just speaking on podcasts like this
but actively participating with my time
and money
and so i'm and because i'm
there's so much hope in this and there's
actually an asymmetric bet
for value gain too
i've just decided
where i can when i can i'm going to pay
you with lightning
when i
where i'm going to invest in these
businesses and
and and start spending way more of my
time in this space
because that time is more valuable
than than
fighting a system that can't win
the system can't change itself and so
and and and
and it's going to be as
for everybody it's going to be
challenging in the as we as we move
through this this can be really chaotic
because a world you're living living in
is is going through a phase transition
and it's going you're going to want to
reach in to all the hate that is coming
from this system
and and
and if you're spending all your time
hating what's what's happening which is
just a function of a structure
you probably end up unhappy
i'm just going to spend more time in the
in the in the news in the new system
doing everything i can
with my time and energy to expand it
yeah it um it does focus you i think
that's one of the the big things is uh
most investors they look across
industries or uh one day you may be
looking at a you know enterprise
software product the next day you may be
looking at a ride-sharing product um and
uh one of the things i think bitcoin has
uh has done for me and many other people
is
it drives focus and you start to think
about this one single system and
there's not very many um
corollaries in history but uh when you
try to
say to yourself i want to be as best
informed as possible about a single
system
and that single system could become uh
the equivalent of an operating system
for humanity globally
it's probably the right place
it is the internet in 95 it's 96 it's
it's literally how an open monetary
network
that is that
everything's porting to being built on
top of it by the way if you talked about
altcoins and everything else and you
take out
the perception of what's happening and
from the bitcoin maxi space to the
altcoins actually if i said i understand
why an entrepreneur
built onto ethereum to try to create
value
when bitcoin didn't offer the ability to
do a bunch of the
a bunch of smart contracts or anything
else on the second layer because because
a choice and simplicity and
decentralization was made on bitcoin
that wasn't made
over here so you could do more things on
on these other
contracts
and a bunch of the entrepreneurs in
those spaces have been labeled and
everything else but if you actually look
at the entrepreneur they're just trying
to create a good business and once
they're on top of that
structure they don't really have an exit
valve and the in their and their
and their structure they're building on
is like building on quicksand
and and and it keeps shifting and and
and but if you have a bunch of business
on that you're trying to protect ever
you're trying to protect your business
and you have employees they have to go
home and
to their families and you're trying to
do everything to protect your business
on quicksand
and what bitcoin offers and so what's
hap going to happen and it's really i
don't think a lot of people know this
yet but it's all
the entrepreneurial talent is all going
to move over on top of a base layer
that's incorruptible if it's not built
on quicksand and so what the
what that form factor what's going to
come on top of it layer two three
three is it's going to look a lot like
the internet um and and it's just wildly
exciting what's it's
what's about to happen in this space and
that value that it'll drive to society
yeah i completely agree
um where can we send people to find you
on the internet and uh anything that you
want to share in terms of where you're
posting a lot of these ideas outside of
like maybe twitter
twitter's probably the best i i did it
connects to a bunch of the uh the other
things i haven't updated my website in a
long time and i don't try to
gain value from from these types of
things anyways but twitter at jeffbooth
on twitter is probably best all right
and then uh i i got one fun question for
you which is uh we were talking before
we're recording this during the bitcoin
conference i think you and i are both
probably running on six
hours of sleep multiple nights uh and uh
you made a comment like it feels like
we're in vegas yeah
which there's many way reasons why it
may feel that way yeah it's amazing
when you're not here uh what's your
sleep schedule these days i it's
actually pretty good i probably get
eight hours a night yeah uh what one of
our spots not here
four hours here one of our sponsors is
eight sleep and uh they have this uh
this whole idea of uh eight hours of
sleep you usually get about four hours
of deep sleep yeah right and can they
compress eight hours to six but still
get the same four hours of deep sleep so
you wake up and kind of have all the
same benefits of the eight hours but you
only took six you get two hours back and
uh
when i was going to bed last night i was
thinking myself damn i only got six
hours right uh i really wish that they
were already getting us at the six hour
they're on their way right but like oh
man come on guys speed it up where's
that deflationary force that
just was talking about
um awesome well thank you so much for
taking the time to do this i really
enjoyed it and uh i think that you've
just you've been ahead of this for a
while and uh you know there's uh there's
a uh negative side i think of the story
in terms of uh uh things could get
pretty bad and chaotic and uncertain but
at the same time bitcoin you know is
that way out it is hope and i think as
more people get educated about it
they'll uh they'll be in a better
position yeah completely agree thanks
of course